huge vomit has gone off warp rebellion
and revolution for more than a decade
I've been outside Britain reporting on
some of the big events shaping lives and
views inside back in Britain also known
as the United Kingdom I haven't lived
here since 2005 and I want to find out
just how much has changed over the past
twelve years
[Music]
so they have no family umpires around so
I try to be like mothering of them so
they call me mum my name is Eden is a
woman who knows loneliness she too is a
refugee I know how I started sign oh how
hard it is for people she fled a trail
with just her baby daughter after her
job as a journalist made it too risky to
stay her story's familiar I've reported
on people fleeing war for more than a
decade whilst based abroad but now I'm
at the other end
seeing how Britain treats her refugees
as I don't have family and friends
around as well they can just be together
rather than then make follow him on the
road yeah the football is a common
language for refugees grateful to be in
Britain but who feel largely unwanted
here I would like to change how people
are thinks about sort of fiction asylum
seekers because as you said it's my
title is refugee but my name is Eden dr.
Michael it's not a refugee so I try to
show people refuge sir a hymning but
even with sanctuary there's not always
safety yeah I just have problems with my
next-door neighbours and I was just
freely on the life in my car and then
having bad girls and they used to throw
stones some people my guests and that we
can't see the garden so you feel like
you don't belong
this space again yeah
Eden's daughters still not lost the
refugee tag despite being in the country
since she was 2 and a national ice
skating champion you never heard of
skate in anyway even a snow we know hail
but else now Eden's been living in
Britain for 16 years
this is her home now yet she still
doesn't feel accepted I have a British
passport but I just still an outsider
have a look at this we showed her images
she knows only too well of one of the
most seismic events of the decade the
mass migration of people
[Music]
she was one of these people once
different time different journey but
facing the same prejudices more shots
are fired into the air
[Applause]
hello akbar the muslim choir face right
now shattered into five what do you feel
watching something like that they bring
back lots of memories for you not for
all the kids that I honestly using them
every single day
hard to watch yeah I can't would I agree
that the general British attitude
towards refugees has deteriorated
recently because of the mass vibration
but that's just because it's a lot more
intense because at the end of the day my
mum was a refugee and she came is she
the exact same thing that other people
are doing but it's just because she
didn't come with a load of people at one
time but I do think that it's changed
massively for the worst you again it's
what motivates her why you not a school
today especially helping women in the
same spot she was in not so long ago I
forgot to ask you really strong how are
you things okay and it's better now
and the main important thing is
integration because we have a lot of
barriers to not integrate into the
society and the first thing is the
language people are really trying hard
because we've been through a hardship um
stuff anyway so it makes you really the
strongest pass and to work hard and to
do something and to give back and what
about some people's approach to you when
you're wearing the headscarf I
personally felt it have been I'm brain
yet I'm not very welcome everywhere I go
I am imagine younger
the manager in the bath they said while
wearing this coffee a beautiful lady we
don't know which religion you are but
never I didn't see something like that
because I was scared
chime cuckoos man there's not many
people of my background about any people
of my background that differ but it
seems it takes an awful lot to feel
integrated in Britain today
[Music]
and for some a passport a daughter with
national awards and work devoted to
helping others still isn't enough to
feel included as guys